hey guys as going so apparently you will
really like to that last insights video
it got a really good response and it did
really well so thanks for clicking on
the like button and all that stuff I
figured let's do one more why not
whenever I finish a video I have all
these facts and insights leftover that
couldn't quite fit into it so it feels
good to give them a little home here we
start in the chalice dungeons this time
there's some really weird stuff down
here especially in the deepest depths
how many of you have seen this thing
before it's listed as a labyrinth mole
in the wiki and statistically it has to
be the rarest creature you can find in
blood-borne it's not even listed in the
official guide that's how rare it is it
spits poisonous scooper to you it slaps
you around with its tentacles it can
move its head to either sides of its
body and well obviously it has a grab
attack and I'm not surprised my
character went a little bit insane from
that one anyway in the description below
I have sourced its discovery and you can
come and gawk at it if you want and it's
funny people come to this chalice
dungeon like they would go to look at an
animal in the zoo when I was walking up
to it there were all manner of messages
like half audience with secret or
despicable blobby thing ahead everyone
just comes here to look at this thing
but don't kill it
treat blobby thing with care see if you
can find my message here and did you
know speaking of messages good segue did
you know that if you rate messages as
fine or foul then the messengers will
react they do a little dance when you
rate it as fine and they cry when you
rate it foul sometimes when you go down
a significant path in a chalice dungeon
or in the Nightmare Realm you might
catch these little Blue Lantern guys in
the corner there are actually little
proximity sensors that light their
lanterns so you know that you've been
through here before they're a little
method to stop you getting lost that I
discovered about a week ago so really
useful another thing you might have
noticed on your chalice dungeon
adventures are the Knights wearing plate
since there are no plate wearing Knights
in blood-borne overworld it makes you
wonder what era these Knights were from
in my head Canon may be the first forays
down into the
dungeons were from a time long ago when
plait was still popular and then finally
when they discovered what they were up
against the more experienced phrase down
into the chalice dungeons would have had
the lightweight attire that gurmann used
as a hunter hunting the beasts because
it says in his item description that he
popularized it go through enough rooms
and eventually you'll find one with a
giant bell in it and of course you're
going to ring this thing right you have
to how could you not it's a mistake when
you do what seems like every enemy in
the bloody chalice dungeon will come to
find you and murder you one of the most
interesting things with this Bell is
that you can actually use the music box
item anywhere near the Bell and the Bell
will resonate as if it was hit I've been
trying this music box on everything
lately
eldritch super hidden meanings aside I
guess what's happening here is the Bell
is set as an interactive element of the
world and that the music box checks
everything in its vicinity to elicit a
response from it and I guess that
triggers the Bell and that's exactly
what makes the music box interesting it
actually has more effects than you would
have first thought everyone knows that
Gascoigne reacts to the music box in the
boss fight since it reminds him of his
wife and daughters but did you know that
he also chuckles when you first play at
near him while he's summoned the song
itself is the first few notes of mogo's
lullaby which plays during the wet-nurse
fight what's sort of interesting is that
sometimes if you spam this music box in
this fight it gets the boss caught in
this endless cycle of sidestepping which
is really curious I read about this on
the wiki and I had to give it a go maybe
it's reacting to the tune so far as I
know it's the only creature that does
this sometimes I do wonder if it's a bug
though similar to with the giant Bell
the idea that NPCs react to things that
you do other than attacks and talking is
something I hope they put into future
games take the doll for example a lot of
you probably realized that she responds
to gestures there's no great discovery
here
she'll clap with you when you're excited
she bells back at you and
tilts her head quizzically when you do
something weird it's so endearing my
favorite is when you do the make contact
gesture and this is the gesture that's
used as some sort of communication with
the great ones wait a minute and when
your character switches sides she all of
a sudden decides to clap
maybe she's impressed that you can do it
correctly and it turns out doing it
correctly matters if you make contact
with the brain of mensis until your arms
switch sides
then you get the fully upgraded moon
room which is the one that gives you
more blood echoes and this is the room
that also mentions that the great ones
are sympathetic in spirit which is
appropriate the nightmare of menses
building is one of those places that's
able to be seen from the nightmare
frontier and I love little details like
these it makes you feel a little bit
like you're exploring a real world
blood-borne does it fairly convincingly
other areas I've noticed are that castle
cainhurst can be seen from hemic channel
Lane and you can also see the
observatory at Bergen worth from the
Forbidden Forest are there any are
missing you can let me know in the
comments I probably am missing some the
tenth little insight is to do with the B
straw just like all the force spells in
previous games B straw deflects
projectiles whether it be giant boulders
fireballs bullets you name it just draw
them away number 11 did you know that
there's a hidden exit when you're riding
up the cathedral Ward elevator I didn't
until recently it leads to the top floor
of Cathedral Ward which houses the
formless oedon rune and the urn costume
for the messengers it also lets you do
this number 12 takes us to the abandoned
hunters workshop if you position
yourself here you hear something strange
it's the sound of an old woman laughing
repeating the same sound over and over
again we've actually tracked down this
sound to a door in an alleyway in
Cathedral Ward
Oh deepest widest gratitude yes and it's
a bizarre glitch to say the least it's
so weird that a voice file would just
start playing here and it's especially
weird because this is a voice file
that's located at the end of one
characters line of dialogue and it's not
the full voice file it's very strange
but sometimes in blood-borne things are
in the game without too much purpose
take the ring of betrothal item for
example you find it in d2 marui hill
roots chalice dungeon and you can use it
to propose to analyse the vile blood
queen even with all the hard work that
you do for her you still get rejected
and it turns out you're doing some
pretty gross stuff for her Annalise
enlists hunters who go out and hunt
other hunters so you can get their blood
Drake's and feed them to your queen and
she consumes these so that she can and I
quote one day bear a child of blood but
have you ever looked closely at what the
blood dregs are when you do it makes
sense why they might help her bear a
child of blood they're clearly meant to
resemble the sperm maybe in the DLC
there will be a use for that ring but so
far there's nothing that's been found
another item like this is the yharnam
stone which you get when you kill Queen
yharnam in the chalice dungeon it reads
the Queen lies dead but her horrific
consciousness is only asleep and it
stirs in unsettling motions the yharnam
stone implies that the Queen lives on
whether inside this stone or in the
Nightmare Realm perhaps it reminds me
entirely of an Elise queen of the
vilebloods since she's the only other
character who is immortal and she's
capable of living on in a lump of flesh
and making a mistake there are actually
a lot of connections between these two
characters
I was really excited about this when I
discovered it around the time I was
doing the cainhurst lore video but none
of this information really fit in that
video because it does take a while to
explain but bear with me even the song
that plays during the arms bus fight is
titled queen of the vilebloods
which is the same song that plays when
you fight ligarius who guards the actual
queen of the vilebloods
so let's list some of the connections
there are two undying Queens who leave
behind a bloody token of their
immortality these are two queens that
share the queen of the vilebloods
soundtrack there are also two queens
with strong connections to blood one of
them started a line of followers who
partook of her blood that's Annalise and
the other one wields a kind of blood
sorcery when she fights both of them are
also related to the ring of betrothal
which is a ring found in tomorrow a hill
which is also Queen yharnam chalice
dungeon and the description of the ring
clearly relates to Queen Yanam and Queen
Anne Elise is the only character who
recognizes this ring as a wedding ring a
wedding ring that says it's only
permitted to those who are slated to
bear a special child which is a phrase
that applies to both Queens so I just
rambled on quickly about their
similarities but what does this mean
what are some of the consequences for
blood borns timeline for example well
foul blood as mentioned by alfred was
another strain of the old blood stolen
from Bergen worth long ago by a scholar
and this was likely back when the
scholars were still exploring the tombs
it makes you wonder could Queen yharnam
be the source of this file blood the
thing that seals it for me is the fact
that Queen yharnam of the chalice
dungeons has chains around her wrists
implying that she was perhaps found and
restrained at some point and maybe even
exploited so that the blood could be
taken from her and it could have got
into the populace and eventually led to
the rise of the Val bloodline also
finally when you hit Queen yharnam the
baby mojo screams out she's clearly had
something ripped
from her pregnant stomach perhaps it was
the umbilical cord that granted menses
audience with mergo the infant great one
at the top of the nightmare of menses
this would also explain Queenie Ana's
presence outside after all there are
just so many connections here between
Queenie Onam and the outside world so
I'm curious to see what you guys think
maybe we can take this a little bit
further even and I think this is all I
can think of I don't think I'll be able
to scrape together another 15 things
that are high enough in quality to
include so thanks so much for supporting
this series and I hope you stay tuned
for more blood-borne and Dark Souls 3
stuff in the future and I'll see you in
the next one cheers guys